[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 4 juin voici les titres
de ce journal l'estac a accueilli
aujourd'hui ils imaginent forum mobility
as septième édition cet événement
proposé par l'association move et où il
réunit les principaux acteurs français
du secteur réflexion cette année sur la
mobilité pour tous notamment dans les
zones rurales et périurbaines
un anniversaire à guyancourt la commune
fait 30 ans de jumelage avec la ville
allemande de pénity une délégation était
reçue le week-end dernier pour les
célébrations invités de ce journal
pascal parent et président du comité de
jumelage de guyancourt et lui aussi
soufflé sa trentième bougie le grand
marcheur s'il vient se dérouler dimanche
vide greniers incontournable à bois
d'arcy qui a rassemblé à cette année 600
exposants plusieurs milliers de
personnes s'y sont rendus pour dénicher
de bonnes affaires et sur ce plateau
également à tout à l'heure et xavier
senio il a adapté son roman nemesis en
long métrage première projection très
prochainement on en parle tout à l'heure
pour commencer cette information météo
france a placé les yvelines en alerte
orange aux orages le pic se déroule en
ce moment même et jusqu'à 20h ces orages
s'accompagnent de rafales de vent entre
60 et 70 km/heure pouvant atteindre même
90 km heure par endroits avec des pluies
intenses et de la possibilité de grêle
la préfecture des yvelines appel à la
prudence
elle le conseil municipal du chesnay
rocancourt l'a validée en séance les
élus ont décidé de donner le nom de
jonathan sandler à une allée piétonne de
la ville
celle qui relie la rue du hameau au
caruhel de saint martin et jonathan
sandler l'une des victimes des attentats
de toulouse assassiné avec ses enfants
gabriel et arié devant l'école ozar
hatorah où il était professeur à l'homme
a grandi notamment au chesnay où ses
parents myriam et samuel sandler habite
toujours aujourd'hui en juin 2015 c'est
une autre ville par laquelle jonathan
sandler était passé versailles qui avait
inauguré un square à son nom plus de 300
acteurs majeurs de la mobilité réunit
aujourd'hui à l'estaca le 7e forum
imaging mobility se dérouler sur le
campus de l'école d'ingénieurs basée à
montigny le bretonneux s'est organisée
le pôle de compétitivité movéo un
événement sous la forme de conférences
et d'un forum qui présente une vision
concrète des nouvelles solutions de
déplacement thème cette année la
mobilité pour tous et inclusive
autrement dit pour tous les territoires
zones rurales et périurbaines comprise
le forum est l opportunité de faire se
rencontrer pme et grands groupes du
secteur dans les locaux d'une école
spécialisée justement sur la mobilité et
les propos sont recueillis par nicolas
landry et audrey chaillou le pôle
mauvais au sac altéré 6 et de monter des
projets coopératifs pour lesquels on va
chercher des compétences là où elles se
trouvent donc dans les grands groupes
dans les pme et
et ça c'est des opportunités de créer de
nouvelles initiatives beaucoup de
startups sur le résultat de ces projets
coopératifs
ça nous permet déjà de faire connaître
le campus faire connaître notre école et
surtout de faire venir sur place des
industriels des acteurs majeurs et des
équipementiers du monde de l'automobile
est un site et faire découvrir nos
activités de formation mais aussi de
recherche parce que l'estac à ces deux
laboratoires de recherche spécialisés
dans le domaine des transports et donc
vu les sujets de la mobilité et des
technologies dont on parle d'aujourd'hui
c'est important de les faire rencontrer
nos chercheurs et la journée a été
l'occasion d'une signature movéo a
fusionné avec les associations
régionales de l'industrie automobile
d'île de france et de normandie ce qui
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir un pôle
réunissant est des partenaires de
l'innovation à l'industrialisation
une gare autoroutière bientôt le long de
l'autoroute a10 c'est un projet prévu
pour 2020 des travaux ont été lancés
hier à longvilliers au niveau de la
sortie numéro 20 dourdan
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines le principe
laisser sa voiture gratuitement sur ses
terres pour prendre ensuite un bus et
vous rendre sur votre lieu de travail
cinq lignes desserviront l'espace
équipés de 255 places de parking ces bus
permettront notamment de relier en
quelques minutes la gare rer c et rer b
de massy-palaiseau un chantier de six
millions d'euros financés par vinci
autoroutes est déclaré d'utilité
publique par le département des yvelines
dans l'actualité aussi jusqu'à dimanche
c'est la fête du vélo plusieurs
animations dont des balades et circuits
sont proposés partout en france pour
faire la promotion de ce moyen de
transport le week-end dernier
l'agglomération versailles grand parc à
s'est associé à cet événement avec
l'objectif de développer les
circulations douces sur son territoire
michael et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude le vélo était à
l'honneur ce week-end à versailles grand
parc la communauté d'agglomération a
organisé ce dimanche 2 juin pour la
toute première fois une fête dédiée à la
bicyclette
au programme notamment huit parcours
vélo sur toutes les voies douces du
secteur pour nous c'est un objectif très
important de sensibiliser les gens à
l'utilisation du vélo aussi bien pour
les parcours de de détente que les
parcours aussi en ville pour aller au
bureau et ses allées aux gars donc
on a dit on va développer 90 km de
pistes cyclables et puis on développe
aussi des parkings vélos à l'arrivée
pièce d'eau des suisses à versailles un
village avec des stands a été installé
l'occasion pour les visiteurs de
découvrir velits go un service de
location d'un vélo électrique qui sera
lancé le 10 septembre par la région le
tarif 40 euros par mois pendant six mois
dont la moitié est prise en charge par
l'employeur
l'idée c'est vraiment d'essayer dans le
quotidien de sa vie pendant une longue
période moment où il fait beau des
moments où il pleut et c est ce que le
vélo à assistance électrique mérite
l'investissement qui est quand même
assez important qu'on va faire donc six
mois ça permet de le tester et ensuite
effectivement on le rend ce vélo n'est
pas destiné à être achetés il est
vraiment destiné uniquement à la
location et on le rend pour pour acheter
alors là dans le commerce
les préinscriptions veliko viennent
d'être lancés la fête du vélo est
organisée partout en france jusqu'à ce
dimanche 9 juin et à l'occasion de cette
fête du vélo la vélostation de saint
quentin en yvelines propose des tarifs
réduits
ils vont jusqu'à -70% vous pourrez donc
louer une bicyclette à 10 centimes
d'euro par jour la vélostation est
située juste à côté de l'entrée de la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines place
charles de gaulle à montigny le
bretonneux
première invitée avec moi sur ce plateau
c'est à xavier senio bonsoir ça vous
êtes villepreux dit un professeur de
français écrivain est désormais
réalisateur puisque vous allez projeter
votre premier long métrage nemesis assez
à mardi prochain à 20h30 au cinéma de
fontenay-le-fleury alors c'est
l'adaptation de votre sixième roman du
même nom nemesis avec est un thriller
policier et qui a été récompensé du prix
du polar au salon du livre de
rambouillet c'est l'aboutissement des
avis et ne-yo de cinq années de travail
du coup quel est votre état d'esprit
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est un
soulagement est ce que voilà vous avez
une fierté aussi d'avoir terminé ce
projet bah oui c'est ça c'est les deux
soulagement parce que c'est avec 50
travaillent sur un projet qui entraîne
des centaines de centaines de personnes
il ya plein de fois je me suis dit que
peut-être qu'on ne finira jamais
benouza de nous inviter le monde galère
des choses l'acteur qui part en cours de
route ou autres problèmes donc ça qu'un
gros seins immense soulagement même de
l'avoir fini et oui c'est vrai que c'est
d'une fiat aimé mais aussi beaucoup de
reconnaissance parce qu'il ya quand même
énormément de personnes qui m'ont suivi
du début de mars 2014 à avril 2019 qui
étaient là au début jusqu'à la fin et et
beaucoup de reconnaissance envers tous
ceux qui m'ont aidé et soutenu à
partenaires soutient participer au
projet et on imagine une certaine
excitation avec la projection mardi
prochain va se faire une idée tout de
suite en visionnant un extrait de la
bande annonce
ce pseudo justice qui n'a aucune
légitimité pour faire la loi doit
appliquer la justice
je pense plus dangereux que ceux qu'il
combat dans cette vidéo le poké nappers
société de ses proches ou même on
l'avait ce délinquant et un jour
donc la projection ce mardi aux gens au
cinéma de fontenay-le-fleury alors on
suit au travers de ce film jacques est
un jeune homme qui se réveille à
l'hôpital après un grave accident de
moto et il a une amnésie partielle ça
tout à fait et il va il va dès son
réveil est inculpé de quelque chose on
s'est pas au début mais c'est qui la lie
à la police qui est derrière lui et peu
à peu en fait il y les souvenirs vont
revenir et il va faire en fait un jeu
d'échecs mental entre lui et
l'inspecteur qui inspectera forcément un
coup d'avancé sur lui parce que puisque
il a fait une enquête de pendant des
années à air que jack lui a perdu la
mémoire
on va suivre les aventures de jake alors
c'est adapté je le disais de votre
sixième roman faire du cinéma ce que
c'est une idée qui vous trottait dans la
tête depuis longtemps
bah c'est marrant mais mais oui en fait
de même que c'était tout petit alors que
pourtant je n'ai pas du tout nos milieux
du cinéma
je suis toujours imaginé un jour
réaliser un film après moi je suis à la
base sur romancier ça fait sept ans que
je publie des romans et et puis à côté
j'ai la passion de la photographie puis
naturellement j'ai lié ses deux passions
et ça a donné à la réalisation d'un d'un
long métrage
mais pourquoi le faire sur ce roman
pourquoi avoir sauté le pas sur nemesis
pas sur un autre roman ça se prêtait
peut-être à l'adaptation au cinéma c'est
pas mon premier projet non non j'ai déjà
fait un film il ya six ans qui était un
film amateur au jour le jour qui aussi
lui aussi était l'adaptation d'un mes
romans
j'ai fait plusieurs courts métrages
avant plusieurs séries est donc celui là
je ne sais pas quand j'ai conçu une
histoire avant de l'écrire je trouvais
que c'était très cinématographique
donc j'ai fait les deux en fait le roman
et le film alors 50 travaillent sur ce
projet écrire un roman et écrire un film
on imagine c'est pas la même chose
quelles sont les différences notables un
sac c'est pas du tout la même chose qu'à
autant un roman l'histoire valable elle
est dans notre tête le plomb se fait
dans la tête toutes les idées
l'atmosphère assez dans notre coin et
c'est vrai qu'elle écrit un script j'ai
on était trois protos qu'elle tourne
après le roman puis à partir du moment
où on écrit le script et c'est très
compliqué parce que en fait il ya
tellement de choses qu'il faut penser
quand on écrit va falloir penser à la
mise en scène à comment on enchaîne
est-ce que ça va être long pas assez
long le dial up c'est pas du tout c'est
étonnant mais c'est après ça je fais
vraiment
en détail inscrits aux cylons amis on a
mis une belle année pour les clients
vous êtes arrêté dans l'écriture du
roman pour vous consacrer à l'écriture
du script c'est ça parce que c'était
trop compliqué de faire des dons en
temps je me perdais dans le film
forcément on a fait des concessions il
faut choisir
qu'est-ce qui est importante ici les -
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui va être trop
loin d'exploiter donc il faut remodeler
le scénario du roman pour en faire le
script du film et faire les deux en même
temps c'était trop compliqué je me
perdais vraiment des fois ça se passe
avant mais non ça c'est dans le film ça
se passe avant mais dans le roman ça se
passe après et puis je me perdais trop
donc j'ai arrêté dès qu'un roman pour
finir le script du film et j'ai repris
du coup le roman vous étiez 3 vous l'a
dit sur l'écriture du script vous êtes
entourés de beaucoup de personnes pour
mener ce projet à bien
ga
parler des scripts ou de film sur film
en entrevue que le script c'était trois
personnes le film en fait quand j'ai
fait le générique gérer des cas de
personnes en fait qui ont participé au
film c'est vraiment là que j'ai réalisé
quand j'écoute génériques et les noms
qui défilait qui défilent et qui le
filaient et la légine et qui fait plus
de cinq minutes et je me dis ah ouais
d'accord en fait le nombre de personnes
que ce soit des gens qui ont juste aidé
financièrement par exemple aux projets
ou des gens qui sont investi énormément
même pas vous dire il ya vraiment
énormément de personnes
donc maintenant il est terminé c'est
quoi les prochaines étapes c'est de le
vendre de distribuer peut-être là la
première donc avec le cinéma de fontenay
j'ai chez vous du fond ce n'est parce
que il nous manque au pdg en effet
beaucoup de films là bas et y apprenait
on aurait mal diffusée dans pas mal de
cinéma des yvelines
et puis après pourquoi pas avoir un
distributeur lui distribuer un peu
partout en france dans des festivals
c'est de proposer aussi dans des
festivals y en a de nombreux turcs sur
le cinéma en france
j'ai toujours travaillé comme ça étape
par étape
donc là je pense que mardi prochain la
première à voir le enfin le retour des
spectateurs pour cette première et après
je penserai dans un deuxième temps donc
la diffusion massive un peu partout j'ai
toujours travaillé comme ça ce film je
les fais en pensant étape par étape
toujours toujours toujours sans penser
trop loin parce que sinon je pense que
je serai trop angoissé de me dire macias
tout ça à faire quand je faisais discret
le script je pensais pas du tout
tournage c'est pas du tout l après quand
je faisais tournage pensais pas du tout
musique à la composition des musiques
c'est là par étape une maintenance c'est
cette étape de la distribution rappelle
la projection nemesis ce mardi aux gens
c'est au cinéma de fontenay le fleury à
20h30 merci xavier senio d'être passé
sur ce plateau et réalisateur de ce long
métrage nemesis grand écran toujours
samedi se tenait le 8e festival des clés
du cinéma une après-midi de projections
autour de courts métrages et pour cette
nouvelle édition une quinzaine de films
étaient projetés retour avec marylène
iapichino et mélanie poker un retour
pour certains à guillaume le ville est
sélectionné pour la deuxième fois
il présentait arthur hambourg inspiré de
son enfance sur l'île de la réunion
une histoire d'amitié entre un poète de
la rue et d'un petit garçon les enfants
ils ont
un naturel et une candeur auquel on
n'est pas forcément habitué parce qu'on
a l'habitude de travail avec de lego
c'est à dire nous on est plein d gola
les adultes enfants un peu moins pas
tout de suite ils ont raison ils ont
huit ans dans le film il était comédien
huit ans les clés du cinéma ont à
nouveau fait le plan près de 200
spectateurs ont répondu présents pour
cette nouvelle édition lancée en 2012 le
festival accueille des réalisateurs
locaux de l'hexagone et internationaux
on demande aux gens qui ont des films
qui sont de catégorie fiction animation
clip ou films autres sauf documentaire
qui chronique pas de candidature on a un
jury de présélection qui en ligne note
les films donc ça nous fait une
présélection qu'on propose à la ville
des claies guy qui valide la sélection
et qui organise à sucre pour cette
huitième édition 13 films étaient en
compétition six prix ont été remis à
l'issue des trois heures de projection
le premier prix du jury a été décerné à
ne demande pas ton chemin de deborah
hassoun ce serait bien de rafale à
papier peint le papier coin et avant de
recevoir mon prochaine invitée mélanie
poquet et sur ce plateau bonsoir un sens
pour votre chronique coup de coeur
culture et on innove un peu on va
écouter tout de suite en extrait
[Musique]
dans son récit
j'aime pas le monopole de l'intelligence
mais j'attends les mots s'envolent
silence alors vous aurez sans doute
reconnu à 5 6 milliards après un an
d'absence le groupe de grenoble remonte
sur scène mélanie et ce sera samedi lors
de la tournée les watts et sinsemilia
c'est même la tête d'affiché du festival
alors le 8 juin les équipes de
métastases vous attend pour pas moins de
dix heures de concert groupes et
artistes vont se relayer durant
l'après-midi la soirée et une partie de
la nuit
un voisin de données notre but c'est
voilà de pouvoir proposer des têtes
d'affiché françaises ou internationales
la scène indépendante est également de
favoriser voilà la diffusion des groupes
émergents à du territoire on est encore
sur un petit fil rouge cette année a le
même style que l'édition précédente
donc on va retrouver de la musique
reggae dub hip hop électro alors la
nouveauté cette année c'est le petit fil
conducteur c'est l'esprit punk la du
punk mélanie avec un groupe au style
bien particulier
si on veut jouer sur les clichés on peut
parler du punk qui sont les endroits
mais plus sérieusement les ramoneurs de
menhirs c'est un groupe breton très
festif sur scène on retrouvera aussi
gérard baste qui est membre du groupe d
une qualif alors quelques artistes que
vous avez cités ils seront dix ans tout
à se succéder la tournée les ouates
cherche aussi à sensibiliser et oui très
sélectif toilettes sèches très animé en
général ça fait l'animation gobelets
réutilisables papier recyclé et pour
vous déplacer jusqu'au site pourquoi ne
pas favoriser le covoiturage le vélo et
toutes les informations sont à retrouver
sur le site du festival
merci mélanie pour cette chronique on
vous retrouve bien sûr après ce journal
aux commandes de votre émission le 7-8
culture nouvelle invitée avec moi en
plateau sait pas ce qu'elle paraît
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
du comité de jumelage de guyancourt
alors la ville qui vient de fêter qui
fête cette année trente ans de jumelage
avec la commune allemande deux pieds
pénit sa pénitence et en bavière
vous avez reçu justement une délégation
bavaroise ce week end à guyancourt une
célébration aussi à ses tenues lors
d'une soirée au pavillon
waldeck-rousseau c'était samedi soir
exactement ce qu'il représente pour
cet anniversaire 30 ans de jumelage ça
fait trente ans d'amitié en fait 30 ans
d' échanges réguliers entre les gens de
guyancourt et légendes pénis entre la
ville de guyancourt et la ville de paint
it avoir entre des associations de
guyancourt et des associations de pénis
et que retenir finalement de ses 30 ans
de jumelage est ce qu'il ya eu des
projets mener des projets phares
peut-être des collaborations à mener
entre les deux villes
des collaborations menée à la hâte le
devil oui enfin à mort on vous parle de
l'historique là on a par exemple monté
sur lui en cours une oktoberfest fête de
la bière une fête de la bière
une fête de la bière sinon c'est certain
c'est presque du quotidien le point clé
c'est tout le week end de l'ascension ou
soit les amis de pénis viennent nous
rendre visite
suivant les années cette année c'était
pas très nombreux ils étaient une
cinquantaine mais ça a pu aller jusqu'à
80 personnes 80 90 personnes ans à 0
quand vous accueillez justement ces
délégations quel est le programme
alors ça se passe sur deux trois jours
la halle ce week-end ça s'est passé sur
deux jours complets sachant que nos amis
allemands arrivent la veille
ils sont arrivés vendredi
jeudi soir jeudi soir j'ai dit soir par
bus le benitz donc on a eu deux journées
de festivités et ils sont repartis
dimanche dans la matinée
donc le principe avait des familles
allemandes sont hébergés par des
familles françaises qui finissent par se
connaître particulièrement bien et au
retour c'est à dire l'année d'après les
familles françaises sont hébergés par
les familles allemand le comité de
jumelage organise ce pendant le week end
avec 1
une première partie donc ça a été
vendredi nous avons emmené nos amis
allemands à chartres et a maintenant
avec deux car enfin bon ça leur a permis
de visiter charte qu'il aura beaucoup
plus et ils ont nous ont demandé de
recommencer l'an prochain en fait de
faire une visite bien complète de chars
vraiment ça ça leur a bien pu manquer de
la visite il y avait de la soirée le
samedi le
le
il ya aussi comme ça c'est le vendredi
nous avons fait un ca conseil
d'administration commun avec nos amis
noté dit souci soir de faire le point
posé un certain nombre d'actions
le lendemain le samedi c'est la journée
en famille
chaque famille reste ou promène ses
propres sa famille allemande amis
suivant un programme qui peut être on
l'a compris l'esprit celle rassemblement
c'est le partage des cultures c'est le
partage des cultures le rassemblement
l'amitié le l'objectif du jumelage de la
fédération mondiale des fils villes
jumelées
c'est de cultiver l'amitié entre les
personnes entre les peuples et favoriser
le développement des langues et guillon
pourrait aussi jumelée avec d'autres
communes 1 depuis 31 ans je crois avec
elle le vide go en écosse et depuis la
mi temps avec la ville béninoise de
comes exactement exactement
il ya tout un tas de collaboration des
changes avec ce qu'ils sont des échanges
scolaires délaissé allemands sont venus
cette année au lycée de villa roi une
semaine donc je les ai croisés parmi les
lycéens allemands qui sont venus
d'ailleurs j'avais hébergé quelques
années avant deux allemands qui étaient
venus avec la fanfare
ça revient finalement à ce travail
quotidien au sein de ce comité de
jumelage ya combien de membres au sein
du comité
il y a à peu près 80 membres en ce
moment et je voulais terminer cet
entretien avec vous parce qu'elle paraît
en parlant d'un membre un membre
spéciale de ce comité de jumelage qui a
été membre depuis 2002 qui était
président aussi à partir de mi-2010 et
george clinton a quitté début 2018 il a
laissé un grand vide
il a laissé un grand vide et les parties
de manière totalement inattendue c'est
dire que personne au comité de l'été
près à son départ c'était un président
extrêmement actif extrêmement dynamique
et entraînant et
bien sûr pris sa suite voilà mais il a
apporté énormément au comité le dire que
aujourd'hui on pense encore à lui loi on
a fait des fêtes en pensant à huy et et
voilà ils méritent amplement cet hommage
merci pascal parent et président du
comité de jumelage de guyancourt et du
coup bon anniversaire pour ses 30 ans de
mariage avec paint it
merci du en cours jumelée avec paint it
la ville de four qu elle aussi a une
soeur allemande film et pour célébrer ce
lien de jumelage la ville illinoise
organisé samedi dernier est la quatrième
édition de sa fête de la bière il y en a
aussi dans d'autres communes un moment
de partage et de convivialité entre les
participants marylène iapichino et
nicolas d'android
[Musique]
ambiance bavaroise à four que ce samedi
1er juin la quatrième édition de la fête
de la bière pour célébrer le jumelage
avec la ville allemande de cheval mme
yade de la bière qui viennent
d'allemagne des saucisses brad bird qui
sont là qui viennent aussi d'allemagne
qui sont livrés par nos amis allemands
et c'est tout toute l'équipe de
l'association d'une halle où naquit très
cet événement qui organise de tous
l'objectif c'est de passer un moment au
sol et de promouvoir l'échangé
franco-allemand vingt ans d'amitié
franco-allemande au niveau local un
partage culturel de l'art de vivre
autour de la bière produite directement
hblm c'est la crème barreur pis c'est
une bière locale qui est brassée à côté
de chez elle m'a laissé ne peuvent
arrêter de baisser légèrement une pointe
d'amertume
voilà une des finb il voilà un peu un
peu de mousse quand même tourné dans ce
village depuis 30 ans mais on vit tous
aux états unis et on est chez nos
parents se séparent aujourd'hui on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait cette petite
fête dans le village
si vous fait quand même assez plaisir de
pouvoir se retrouver ici comme ça en
famille autour d'une bière sans être en
bas en allemagne
elle est très bonne c'est une bière de
soif allemande en aidant l'ambiance
bilan de ces festivités 300 breadth el
mil saucisses et près de 500 bières
vendues tout cela avec modération bien
sûr
et puis je vous en parlais dans les
titres ce week-end le grand marché
arcisien fêtait ses 30 ans un événement
incontournable à bois d'arcy exposants
les visiteurs étaient nombreux au rendez
vous sur place patrick jacques de
dixmude et le récit de marylène
iapichino les chineurs étaient de sortie
dimanche de juin 600 exposants présents
pour cette 30e édition du marché
artisanal une institution il ya un choix
extraordinaire il ya des chances qu'ils
sont très conviviaux très sympathique
c'est l'adn même de voir si c'est le
grand marcheur 6e s'il fallait garder
assez l'événement c'est çui là
l'occasion de se débarrasser de vieilles
affaires après son grand ménage de
printemps un peu de tout ce qu'on
ce que notre fils n'utilise plus par
exemple comme il est petit grandi il
faut faut recycler faire profiter les
autres
visite en suisse entre les rue
robespierre du parc et l'avenue paul
vaillant couturier
une petite bête sans huile sur sa
banquise arcisienne niant que ces
exposants tu fasses l'animation fois les
affaires ça se passe très très bien
les gens sont accueillants et puis
j'aimerais bien trouver un petit un papa
pour une maman pour ce petit pingouin
ce que je peux pas je travaille toute la
journée espérons pour ce petit pingouin
qu'il ait trouvé preneur pour le reste
la commune avait mis en place des points
relais pour se débarrasser tout en
réalisant une action solidaire
voilà phase voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal cette information avant de vous
laisser météo france qui a placé les
yvelines en alerte orange pour les
orages le pic se déroule en ce moment
même et ce jusqu'à 20 heures avec des
rafales de vent la préfecture des
yvelines appel à la prudence et belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]